The Joe Rogan.
Experience. It's always hard for me at the airport. When I see like, uh,
like a drug sniffing working dog, but it's like a yellow lab.
I'm like really pet, I can't pet the yellow lab. I don't, I don't.
You could ruin the dog.
I don't wanna ruin the dog and his chances at retirement, you could ruin.
It. I'm not going to, yeah. Those drugs,
drug sniffing dogs make me nervous, cuz I'm like, what are they looking for?
Not weed that's truth, but you could only teach a dog to look for one thing,
you know, you can't say, Hey, I want the truth, the truth.
You can't teach a dog. Hey, I want you to look for guns and Coke. Right.
It's like residue.
Right. Do smell.
Right, right. Do you smell gun powder? Do you smell marijuana?
Like what do you smell? Like what do you, what do you train? You train.
The dog to smell heroin. You find, uh, mushrooms. Bring them back. Right?
Find them find 'em you little.
Yeah, definitely the heroin. Cause I think you can make more things out of that.
Uh, well it's one that kills you.
It's one of the reasons why they should look out for heroin. Fentanyl.
If they could smell fentanyl, that would be nice. They could smell anything.
But.
I feel like fentanyls it's more local. Oh actually, no,
I don't know what I'm talking about. I feel like with prescription drugs,
like that's more like it ravages a community.
And I don't when I think of like airplanes,
I think like weight being pushed through from other countries. But I don't know.
I think it's all things, meth. It's everything.
It's the really up part about it is.
It's almost like what we were talking about with football.
That football be safer. If there was no helmets, it doesn't make sense.
And drugs would.
Be safer if they.
Regulate it. We would safer if they.
Were legal. I feel that way about prostitution. Yeah.
And I'm gonna actually broach this here. I was gonna write a joke about it.
I'm just gonna say it. I believe a state issued. If you apply for funding,
uh, for support,
if you're going to school like loan or the state's paying for you to go to
school, you get a scholarship.
You should also be able to apply for a state issued prostitute.
If you are a little socially awkward,
maybe you haven't had sex because men get weird.
If they haven't been made privy to the way a woman is,
or they haven't had sex and you're going to college, let's get you a prostitute.
Let's get you having sex twice a week. So you, you're not afraid of women.
Let's get you a little less weird. Let's fund a prostitute.
Well, I think if it didn't have the social stigma behind it,
there's a lot of people that would choose it overworking at Wendy's great.
Did a lot of people that choose it. But we long as an it's a choice.
The social stigma is that there's something wrong with it. Right's.
Because it's a woman saying I wanna do this with my body.
That's what's upsetting that. It's sort.
Of that, but it's also, well in this country,
it's also connected to sex slavery. We think of it as like,
if someone is doing that, then maybe, maybe they're a sex slave.
Like maybe there's someone who's. I think.
That's less on people's radars.
And it more has to do with the puritanical idea of.
There's a little bit of that. But I mean,
that was one of the things that they were accusing Robert Craft of you remember
Robert Craft? Who's the guy who owns the craft or it's craft. Right?
He's the guy who owned the new England Patriots.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> mm-hmm <affirmative> mm-hmm <affirmative> he went to a
massage power in the game of happy ending. And then the next thing you know,
they, you know, they arrested him and told him that there's a video of it.
Right. And they were, you know,
they're trying to get him to plead guilty and all this,
all this different that was going on to a guy who's like insanely insanely
wealthy, who just was going there to get jerked off.
But one of the things they said was that it was, uh,
that he was participating somehow in sex trafficking.
And so they were accusing him of that. They were,
that was a big part of what the police were saying. Well,
it turned out that none of the girls that worked there were sex traffickers.
They're just prostitute. And the woman that did it to him,
she was like 40 years old. But none of.
This would've happened. If it was legal, none of it would.
Regulated legal, but it's also, they, they were using that term to,
they were accusing him of this thing and using that term, like to, to brand him,
wait.
Are you telling me that to shame him?
There was a news story where they used a buzzword.
Yes. Yeah. It is a buzzword. Right. But it's a buzzword. That's,
it's very specific in terms of like the difference in the consequences that you
would want someone to face,
whether they just went there to get jerked off or they participated in sex
slavery. Right. You're.
Not a part of a ring. I mean, you are cuz the ring ends with you.
So because there's a demand for it, there is a supply.
So that is by and large part, part of the issue. Um, and I say this,
not knowing a ton about sex slavery,
but I do know that if you take away the stigma and you can normalize things very
quickly, weed is a great example. Mm-hmm <affirmative> right. Yeah.
You could do that.
And even we've done this with women and bodies and the way that we look at
people who are overweight and we look at people with different things.
Like we are getting to a place where it's less of a thing.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> I think you could do that with prostitution. I so too. And,
and it's fine. And look at it as like, this is her choice. And if there,
if there wasn't an exceptional exorbitant demand for it, it wouldn't be a thing.
Yeah. It's just, you,
you can't tell people what to do with their bodies any other way,
except when money's involved. Yeah. That's why I have a problem with it. Except.
When taxes are.
Involved. Yeah. But it's, it's, it's not even that it's, it's,
it's a societal position, right? Like if we were gonna vote on it,
most people would vote on no prostitution cuz they don't want their daughter or
their sister, their mother to be a prostitute. That's how that's or, or them,
they don't wanna be a prostitute. That's why they would vote on it.
But it's the only thing that's completely legal to do.
Like not only that, but it's what sells everything.
When Brandon hit is selling cologne, he's selling, I'm a hot man. If you,
if you get my cologne, you might get some pusy I'm looking right.
At that mouth. Yes.
Look at him. It's beautiful. I, I agree. But that is the thing that is,
is up about all this.
Like a woman can have sex with as many people as she wants for free
mm-hmm <affirmative> she charges then all sudden incr. But, but,
but you can charge for a back rub. Like what the? Like why.
Is it you're like I'm getting off either way.
But it doesn't just doesn't make any sense. It's I agree with you. It's silly.
It's restrictive.
Think when it comes to the idea of a woman taking control of her own body,
no taxes being paid, uh,
and the idea of someone and being a because of our puritanical roots in this
country, all those things combined make it a volatile topic.
But at the end of the day, if she's gonna make money,
that's gonna go back into your society. That's gonna be put to good use.
It's gonna be tax. It's gonna be in your community. What do you care?
What she's doing behind closed doors,
if it's safe and it's regulated just like weed,
all of a sudden there's standards. Now there's a way to, uh, sanitize.
This. Yeah, I think so. And they did it in Australia. They did it in Nevada.
Yeah. And parts of it, parts of it. Right. Um, but in Australia they have,
I mean, it's full on there. You can do whatever you want. They have,
they have brothels.
But I think it's also one of the things that we're conditioned to have a
perspective on it, similar to the drug issue.
Like I don't want my friends or my daughters or my mother or
anyone I know to be a prostitute. Right. So we have this,
like this position on it. I also don't want them to do Coke,
but I don't think Coke should be illegal. I,
I don't think anybody should be able to lock you in a cage cuz you want to get
coked up. Imagine.
If it were legal, how many less people would be dying just in a drug trade.
Yes.
And how many more people would be aware of how much you can do because you'd get
actual Coke with a lot of the you're getting is being cut because you're getting
it. You're buying it from people that aren't companies. Right.
If you're gonna buy something, Nabisco, Nabisco was selling Coke,
put the ingredients on it. It'd be a hundred percent Coke.
You'd be able to get real Coke.
Real Coke, Nabisco flavored cocaine. Moreover I mean, look in Europe,
the way that they are with alcohol. Like Italy, for example. Yes.
Kids have wine when they're little and sure there's alcoholics there,
but it's way less.
It's less of like a rum Springer freak out when you are able to do something.
That's.
A great way to put it a rum Springer freak out that. Yeah.
What she's talking about, if you don't know,
is the Amish have a thing it's when they turn like 18, right?
Something like that. They get to go ham. They get to do whatever they want.
They could watch TV, they could drink smoke pot and.
And they go crazy for a short period of time. And then at the end of that time,
they can either leave the church forever or come back.
And most of them come back. Right. Because it's all, you know,
also you're probably so hung over. Like Jesus, someone.
Make me some.
OCAS get me back. Cutting logs.
This is real workout.